tapons changeront chanson en deux
secondes c'est fait une torche
biologique elle prend du temps il est
habilité impulsivité manque de
concentration tous des effets néfastes
de l'adaptation de notre corps à ces
changements d'heure abrupte d'une grande
synchronisation entre le sommeil la
sécrétion de certaines hormones notre
d'autres capacités de performer dans la
journée m en mémoire ce qu'on a un prix
fait bousculer tout à coup c'est un
effet dépressif sur nos jours les jeunes
qui au de dépression saisonnière le
consensus est bien établie parmi les
scientifiques et les cliniciens du
sommeil le changement d'heure est
nuisible pour la santé
alors pourquoi continue-t-on de le faire
parce que les leaders ne se sont pas
tous penchés sur la question évidemment
la difficulté c'est de coordonner tous
les états et toutes les provinces
d'amérique du nord parce que si on se
met à changer d'une province à l'autre
et d'un état à l'autre ça peut devenir
extrêmement compliqué de suivre le
rythme il faudrait aussi s'entendre sur
l'art qu'on adapterait ça va soulever le
débat de savoir à quelle heure est ce
qu'on veut demeurer l'heure solaire leur
avancée le discours idée du contre dans
les deux camps
malgré les difficultés l'e10 circule de
plus en plus l'ontario a affirmé qu'elle
arrêterait de changer l'heure si le
québec le manitoba et certains états
américains embarqués aussi dans le
mouvement il ya moins de deux semaines
les albertains se sont prononcés sur la
question une mince majorité a choisi de
continuer à changer leur l'amérique du
nord est l'un des seuls endroits dans le
monde où il faut encore ajuster son
cadran récemment d'autres pays ont
décidé d'arrêter cette pratique dont la
russie l'argentine et la tunisie les
européens s'étaient positionnés à 84% en
faveur de conserver toujours la même
heure une directive en ce sens devait
être adoptée par le conseil de l'union
européenne
mais ça a été relégué aux oubliettes en
raison de la pandémie ici à l'excès en
dribbles et le radio canada montréal